alright now that our thumbnails grab
your attention relax
your favorite competitive game isn't
dead unless it happens to be artifact in
that case why is one man spared another
taken death comes for us all look we've
all seen the troll baby edge Lord posts
on reddit or scroll through a swath of
YouTube videos dancing upon the supposed
graves of certain games and in most
cases these hot takes are either
childish attempt at inciting flame wars
or melodramatic ways of drawing negative
attention towards games or patches that
leave something to be desired
it sucks but what exactly qualifies a
game is dead and what kind of impact can
this unpleasant label have on these
titles and the people that are actually
playing them what are you playing
oh it's actually the original Halo it's
got a fantastic spawn system the
shooting is really fluid it's actually a
really grow a dead game
[Music]
surprisingly the term dead game didn't
start out as a shed posting meme but as
a genuine attempt at describing a game
that has been abandoned by its player
base that makes so much sense usually
when we talk about dead games the
moniker is directed at multiplayer
titles since single-player experiences
will never cease to exist unless a game
is literally pulled from shelves and
digital storefronts truly dead games are
typically defined by the fact that
they're legitimately unplayable either
their developers of abandoned support
for them or their servers have gone
offline forever
so that's it we are now going back we're
being forcefully disconnected from the
server a lot back in and as you can see
you can get to the server select screen
[Music]
and if we take a stroll through the
cemetery of dead games we'll find a slew
of titles from all sorts of genres from
mmo's like tabula rasa to FPS is like
lawbreakers to even MOBAs like heroes of
the storm well I was never dead alright
I was just resting my eyes
as a meme dead game calls the relevance
of a title into question
it's a groin shot characterization
that's launched it's basically any game
that's fallen out of favor and what game
fits that mold better than Starcraft 2
an RTS that in its prime contributed
massively to the growth of eSports but
has been on life support for the past
few years so how did the king of
competitive gaming take such a dramatic
nosedive well Starcraft twos troubles
began with heart of the swarm an
expansion that was poorly received by
its community at launch that in
combination with other more accessible
eSports titles rising up in Blizzard
choosing to region-locked the game in
2015 spelled the end to its reign at the
top but here's the thing there are still
enough active Starcraft 2 players to
warn keeping the server's alive even at
a competitive level there are still huge
tournaments every year and the most
dedicated parts of the community
continue to endure
anyway on top of being used as clickbait
or as a cheap shot meme the dead game
label is also used as a gatekeeping
tactic that keeps certain games at the
top of the tier list but sometimes those
games don't need help staying on top
when they're supposed challengers our
absolute [__] and yes we're talking
about the culling too I mean the
mechanics are bad it's very clearly not
done the graphics and I hate complaining
about graphics but it's hard not to you
in this case
look like PlayStation 2 the audience
response to this awful battle royale
cash grab was so negative that two days
after its launch in 2018 there were
thirteen [__] people on its servers I
think most of you know that last week we
launched the culling - and that launch
was not successful the culling tube
bombed so hard that it was pulled from
Steam and in May its servers were shut
down entirely officially making it a
dead game but games don't have to be
complete dumpster fires to be branded
dead sometimes they can be sabotage even
by their own fan bases just look at
Marvel vs. Capcom infinite while it's
not perfect by any stretch of the
imagination worse fighting games have
been made but fans of the franchise were
so displeased with Capcom's offering
that infinite arrived - almost unanimous
indifference
[Music]
nobody cares nobody cares games like
split gate arena and battle right
experience similar situations although
both had interesting takes on establish
genres both also suffered from buggy
launches and struggled to grow their
respective audiences their Doom's were
sealed once the larger gaming community
and its hordes of sheeple proclaim they
were dead foes the herd bizarrely every
now and then healthy games are guided to
irrelevance by their very creators just
look at any ea sports game from the last
20 years or better yet the Call of Duty
franchise which has compromised the
continuity of its competitive scene
because Activision insists on endlessly
creating sequels approaches like this
force games to kick the bucket before
they can naturally decline in popularity
robbing communities of playtime for the
sake of cashing in on an improved sequel
however every now and then we bear
witness to a miracle and games that seem
destined to die are given a new lease on
life look no further than Rainbow six
siege Ubisoft's MOBA inspired FPS to put
it bluntly in its first year siege made
a pretty awful impression with most
players mainly because it felt
incomplete was littered with bugs and on
top of that it took what felt like an
eternity to find a game it's been 84
years but by actually listening to their
player base and its dedicated group of
content creators Ubisoft was able to
reverse sieges fate I think to me that's
one of the aspects that is the most
critical for us is how much we are
looking at the engage players and the
people that are trusting us and being
with us for such a long time they are
the one that gave us feedback the other
one that has peaked with us through
operation health and when matchmaking
was really crap really a hats off to
those guys because they have been
through the moments when the game was
really not in a good place and that part
of why now
other people jump in and there's a lot
play base although a few games are
turned from the brink of dead game
status at the end of the day who gives a
flying [__] what the internet thinks
what really matters most is what you
think of your game because it only truly
dies when you choose to stop playing
[Music]
didn't you write this hey the office is
closing play that dead game at home it's
not dead and I'm not going anywhere
lack of rock [__] Chevy torsos how
couldst role is acting be like a rock
nothing else I've got to mean I'm not a
crock Oh